now as we've been reporting the Prime
Minister has rolled out a Canada style
trade deal with the European Union which
is supported by many conservative MPs
Theresa May said it would be worse than
no deal at all she's been speaking to
our political correspondent Tom Rayner
well first of all what I have said is
that no deal would be better than a bad
deal you talk about a Canada style deal
actually that's not on the table it's
not on the table for the United Kingdom
what is on the table from the European
Union is effectively breaking up the
United Kingdom by having a trade
agreement with Great Britain and keeping
Northern Ireland in the single mark most
of the single market and the customs
union creating a customs border down the
RSC effectively carving Northern Ireland
away from the rest of the United Kingdom
what we've put on the table what the
British government has put on the table
is a proposal that respects the vote of
the British people that delivers what
they what they were voting for can enter
free movement and the jurisdiction of
the European Court of Justice but does
so in a way that protects the Union of
the United Kingdom delivers no hard
border for Northern Ireland Ireland and
protects jobs in the UK just to be clear
though what you're saying is a No Deal
bricks it is a price worth paying
for keeping Northern Ireland out of the
customs union just to be absolutely
clear that is what you're saying now
what I'm saying what we're doing is
working for a good deal and a good deal
that ensures that we keep the integrity
constitutional integrity of the United
Kingdom a deal that delivers for people
by protecting jobs but also delivers for
people by delivering on their vote and
ensuring that we respect that vote we
leave the European Union into the
jurisdiction of the European Court enter
free movement after the Common
Agricultural Policy out of the Common
Fisheries Policy a No Deal scenario is
now a real prospect you've said that
gives your self and you said it's
something that you are not scared of if
it were to come to that but would you
accept than a No Deal breaks it would be
ultimately a failure I what I'm very
clear about is that we're working for a
good deal but because we don't know what
the outcome of the negotiations is going
to be it is absolutely right that the
government is preparing for the
possibility of No Deal
that is common sense regretting those
making it's common sense I'm working for
a good deal I'm working for a deal with
the European Union but we prepare for
the possibility of no
because I want to ensure that when we
leave the European Union we make a
success of it regardless of the deal
that we've arranged if it is the case
that Britain leaves without a deal would
you consider resigning would you
consider it a failure of your intentions
to try and get to deal what I'm doing is
working to get a deal with the European
Union what we see from comments from
others in the European Union and this
has been echoed for example by the Irish
Prime Minister the tea shop today is
that there's a prospect of getting that
deal that there is a feeling that people
actually do want to ensure that we get
that deal so let's go out there let's
work which I've said to the European
Union there are two issues on the table
the backstop so-called backstop the
Northern Ireland border issue under the
withdrawal agreement we will be putting
our proposals forward on that before the
estimates on the on the future economic
partnership we have said to the European
Union if they have problems with the
proposal we've put forward let's hear
what those problems are let's hear any
counter proposals they have and then we
can negotiate on them in terms of
counter proposals with the Irish
backstop are you ultimately looking at a
regulatory border in the Irish Sea what
we're looking at is addressing the issue
of ensuring that if in the circumstances
where our future economic relationship
the future trading a relationship with
Europe has been agreed but there's a
delay in putting it into practice that
we ensure that for that period of that
delay there will be no hard border
between Northern Ireland and Ireland how
about a regulation coming to Jersey
looking at the various aspects that need
to be dealt with in order to do that we
will bring forward our proposals in due
course on that and we recognize the
importance of that we committed to
agreeing a backstop but also I believe
that for the future relationship
frictionless trade with Europe lies at
its heart that's how we can ensure
sustainably into the future no hard
border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland Prime Minister if as you are
saying you believe that you can get a
deal and you believe that when they look
the deal in the face in the moment that
MPs will come round to believing it is
the right option for the United Kingdom
if they don't
however are there any circumstances
where you believe it would be in the
national interest to call another
general election I what I'm working for
is a good deal I'm working to bring that
good deal back from Europe and I believe
at that we just rule it out yeah if I
said what I'm working for is a good deal
we're putting the effort in we're
setting out the issues in which we
believe the European Union should
respond very clearly if they've got
concerns with the proposal we've put
forward let's hear those concerns it's
not it is not in the national interest
to have a general election we're working
in the national interest for the right
relationship with Europe in the future
just finally Prime Minister I know that
you didn't explicitly rule it out early
so it's not in the national interest Sky
News is running a campaign to make
debates happen all the other party
leaders have signed up to the creation
the idea of a creation of an independent
commission to organize and run televised
debates ahead of a general election will
you support that proposal the next
general election is in 2022 there's
plenty of time to think about those
issues at that time what we're what
we're focused on now is actually
ensuring that we're working to get that
good deal from the European Union while
it's in the interests of people across
the whole of the United Kingdom